there are two types of mindset we can
cultivate one that embraces problems as
opportunities to learn and one that
avoids them often out of fear to fail
people that avoid conflicts can be
described as having a fixed mindset
those who see problems as interesting
challenges have a growth mindset
sometimes we like to switch from one to
the other people have a fixed mindset
because they believe the basic qualities
like intelligence or talents a fixed
traits and that these traits are
responsible for success they often like
to document past achievements with a
growth mindset people believe that new
abilities can be developed through
practice this view creates the love for
learning but most great leaders and
artists have in common for them life
becomes an exciting journey with endless
opportunity to figure out new things and
advance to develop a growth mindset dr.
Carol Dweck the Stanford University
professor who coined the term advises
leaders teachers and parents to
celebrate trying teachers should applaud
students for any grade if they studied
hard parents should encourage their
children to develop any new skill they
are interested in doing this will make
them learn the skill of learning which
will also help them back in the
classroom to illustrate the difference
in everyday life let's observe two
imaginary kids Jay thinks you've either
got it or you haven't and note that she
can learn anything if she wants it
enough
at physical exercise J avoids challenges
when it's time to jump over the vaulting
horse he's afraid to look stupid and be
laughed at and embraces any challenge
it's exciting it's fun
she knows that failing is part of
learning and if she tries hard at the
end nobody will laugh at her J avoids
feedback if the teacher tells him how to
improve an assignment he has been
working on
he takes it personally and knows that to
improve she needs to listen to
constructive criticism she also
understands that it's not her that is
being assessed but the results of her
work on that one day J always takes the
easy road for example he likes
escalators and hates to take the stairs
when he is practicing the guitar he
stomps the moment he's getting stuck and
usually doesn't even take escalators she
jumps up the stairs counts every step in
her head and enjoys filling the blood
rushing through her veins she practices
the drums every morning for 15 minutes
not that she always enjoys it but she
knows that effort is part of a journey
to a more fun life and likes to see
others succeed it inspires her she knows
that if she motivates her friends to get
better she herself is likely to grow too
if his friends try new things and
succeed J feels threatened he's afraid
that their success will put pressure on
him to do more with his life two modern
companies look for employees with a
growth mindset because they solve
problems and persist despite obstacles
to spot the right ones some ask during
the interview whether the job applicant
believes if managers are born or if
management is a skill learned J thinks
that managers are born and gets the job
neuroscientists support the idea they
confirm that the brain grows like any
other muscle in the body with training
studies show that adopted twins tend to
have higher intelligence compared to
their siblings who stayed with their
biological parents the difference
appears to come from the higher
educational levels of adoptive parents
and shows that nurture is more important
than nature a simple switch in how a
person views a situation can mean the
world of difference not just the outcome
of that situation the outcome of that
person's place in life as the late poet
Samuel Beckett once said ever tried ever
failed no matter
try again fail again fail better what do
you think about the concept is it overly
simplistic and if you buy the idea do
you believe it is possible to make a
permanent switch from a fixed to a
growth mindset please share your
thoughts in the comment section below
you
you